Duc des Lombards jazz Affairs je voulais
vous signaler également encore en en
matière musicale les Francophonies en
Limousin c'est jusqu'au 10 octobre fin
de cette émission merci mine merci
messieur de nous avoir accompagné ce
soir ben comme d'hab la peine de mort
n'a toujours pas été ol aux États-Unis
sachez que le Congrès mondial pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort a lieu
début octobre au Canada par ailleurs il
y avait en France au 1er septembre de
cette année
56271 détenus dans les prisons pour
ceement
49595 places à la semaine prochaine
bonsoir bonne
nuit
اناورقهسك
الليقط من
الع
وصرته يا وزين
ران هي
ماعرف
وصرته وزين
ران